with us now from Florida is the mayor of
Hollywood Florida
Josh levy good morning mr. mayor morning
obviously their investigation is going
to be underway but what can you tell us
when you have a situation in which
something is described as an oven how
could this happen
look we're so we're so saddened by this
occurrence to have a people lose their
life due to the apparent negligence of
the staff of a nursing home facility
that that couldn't raise the red flag
soon enough and it wasn't until the
paramedics arrived and and the calls you
know came in that it was demanded that
an inspection of the entire facility
take place until dead bodies were
discovered I know there are so many
questions and what do you say what I
think offends most people is that
there's a hospital right across the
street that had air-conditioned
facilities I'm sure you've asked the
question to the staff about what
happened here why didn't you guys do
something what is the answer that you
have gotten well clearly as you can
imagine there's a non going criminal
investigation the only persons with the
city of Hollywood this staff was
interviewing with yesterday would have
been homicide investigators a hundred
and fifty of the 700 nursing homes in
Florida are reportedly without power
there are also 42 other facilities in
Hollywood where you are what can you say
about assuring people who have family
members are that this won't happen again
look we live in Florida we are in a
tropical climate hurricanes are a fact
of life and when state regulators enact
laws requiring for example the idea of
backup generators for nursing homes they
need to be aware that needs to be
enforced and that needs to be regulated
and required in Florida it's interesting
we require gas stations to have backup
generators but apparently given how many
nursing home facilities in Florida were
reported 150 si did not have power still
right now or as of yesterday it doesn't
seem like there's a requirement for
nursing homes to have a backup generator
but yet for gas stations we do and how
fast will it take you to change that
look I know that this event will will
raise awareness to this circumstance I
expect the legislature going into
session later this year actually will
not will not avoid looking at this this
needs to be looked at right away by our
state and the regulating agencies and
action needs to be taken I think this
makes it more clear than ever
yeah well mayor josh levy we're sorry
for what people have had to suffer there
and thank you for joining us this
morning